our gold medal award goes to a film made
at the University of Westminster and the
United Kingdom I might add that this is
a first time win for that school in the
student awards directed by David
Winstone the film for LC tells the story
of a down-on-his-luck piano teacher a
Russian gangster and his daughter and a
day that may go down in piano lesson
history who this is a an amazing moment
for me not just because this award but
also because I've actually been in love
with Lord done since I was five years
old for me Jurassic Park was that movie
that kind of made me fall in love in
movies and I watched it every day for
maybe three years when I was a kid
before school so I was real honor and
now I'm really embarrassed but nice it's
been an unbelievable week I mean it's
such such an honor to be recognized this
highly at this young age I think it's
worth noting that that me and my crew
were all 21 max when we made this film
we're all 22 23 now so yeah give us lots
of money and yeah it's been a great week
and I've learned so much and anyone's
films blew me away you should definitely
check them out they've inspiring and
beautiful and I like I made a lot of
good friends and if any of them need a
place to crash in London ever they
welcome to stay on my couch but yet
thank you so much to the Academy sorry
well I really hope hardly want to thank
my cast and crew you know I as the
director I get to go to all these cool
things and glamorous events and fly
around the world and steal all the
credit and it's totally unfair they
fully deserve to be up here with me and
I'm glad some of them including some of
my best friends are here with me too
right yeah and yeah I mean it's just
they all made me look good and I'm
really grateful to them and I can't wait
to make the next project with them I
also want to thank my University the
University of Westminster when I think
back to my first day there and to where
I am now it's kind of ridiculous and I
like Kerry believe it and I learned so
much and I just really want to take this
opportunity to thank all the teachers
and lecturers and all the faculty at the
in the television and film deployment
nur they were amazing and this film is
such a credit to them and yeah I liked
so much finally I'm a more personal I
really want to thank my parents like
everybody else but I really do because
they are not only did they do they did
stuff on the film as well my dad found
when the locations and my mum made
sandwiches for everyone yeah you think
you're a big-time director and then your
mom turns up and set with your pack
lunch and it's a bit but um yeah it's a
no but seriously though they they've
been completely amazing and
unconditionally supportive i'd say i
think a lot of people here know that
it's difficult probably i don't know but
as a parent to to be so supportive of
that child when they go into an industry
it's difficult in turbulent as this one
but my parents completely ever since
they saw my reaction to Jurassic Park
and I was five years old have been I've
been I've been fully supportive and and
labor them they completely believed in
me I think more than I could ever
believe in myself so that's I really
needed that and so yeah sorry thanks mom
and dad and thank you all so much thank
you